[Music]
good afternoon everybody and my name is
Marcus East I have the best job in the
world in that I'm the chief technology
officer for National Geographic and what
you just saw on screen there was just a
slice of the National Geographic image
collection now we don't think of those
assets just as digital files every
single one of those pictures that you
saw tells a story they're the stories of
adventurers who've been around the world
to explore unknown places photographers
who are trying to capture their
knowledge of the world or researchers
who are trying to help us better
understand the planet around us and we
take our responsibilities at National
Geographic very seriously as the
custodians of those images because those
images help to tell stories and those
stories help to improve people's
knowledge of the planet Earth of its
people its animals and its places and by
doing so we hope that we can help people
to care more about the planet because if
they care more about the planet they're
more likely to protect the planet and so
our team is incredibly excited for that
not only do we do things that are
fantastic from a technology perspective
but we have an opportunity to do things
are actually meaningful to society so
those beautiful images many of which
that you recognized obviously have to be
supported by a great technology platform
and a National Geographic we had what we
called a system all spy and spy was
effectively the home for these wonderful
images it had roughly 17 terabytes of
data housing two million iconic images
that have really helped over the last
hundred and thirty years to shape the
narrative coming out of National
Geographic it probably won't surprise
you to hear though that over the last 20
years the team that's responsible for
running our image collection had built
they would describe it as lovingly
hand-built an application in Java that
was over a period of 20 years iterated
upon we discovered there was not much
documentation unfortunately I'm sure
that's a situation that none of you have
ever experienced before
it was hosted on premise and it was
managed by an Operations team without
technical oversight and from my
perspective when I first joined National
Geographic two years ago it was obvious
to me that it had what we describe as a
sub optimal information security posture
now that's the situation that was
clearly not acceptable to us and
interestingly that system that was
housing the crown jewels of National
Geographic found itself under intense
scrutiny and our VP of information
security came to me and she said Marcus
I think we have a bit of a problem this
system is not really fit for purpose in
terms of the the legacy that we're
protecting we need to do something about
this and we unfortunately took the
decision to take that system offline and
we worked with the business team to come
up with a solution we helped them to
remediate the issues and after many many
months of this and we realized that this
was actually not going to work and we
had to take some drastic action our CEO
came to my office and said Marcus we
need to do something here I'd like your
team to take responsibility for this and
this was in November of 2018 your team
has to take responsibility for this has
to fix this application and get it back
online and as he was leaving my office
and he said I'm by the way it must be up
by January 2019
so that's obviously not something that
you ever want to hear we had a situation
where the crown jewels of our
organization were in a system that
needed help we had a very limited time
in which to do something and the thing
that was driving the need to do
something was what we call our
storytellers summit where all of the
famous photographers that tell these
National Geographic stories around the
world were coming to Washington DC to
National Geographic headquarters in
order to celebrate photography and
obviously that was not going to be a
great story if we didn't have the
archive up and running the good news is
we like a challenge in the products and
technology function of National
Geographic
in fact two of my colleagues here
Melissa Wiley our VP of digital products
and Mike Deborah my VP of engineering
huddled with me in my office and we said
what are we going to do here in order to
resolve this problem we didn't have much
time we were familiar with the cloud we
had spent a lot of time working on a
migration to the cloud but we realized
that this needed to be something special
something more we decided to reach out
to our friends at Google cloud and the
reason that we did that was not just
because we felt that they had incredible
technology and a great solution to the
problems that we were facing but we felt
there was a alignment of values in our
conversations with them we understood
that they cared as much about the
environment as we do things like
sustainability were things that they
talked about when proposing to us using
Google cloud as a possible platform and
we then set about just before
Thanksgiving the process of putting this
incredibly valuable archive back online
Google worked very closely with us both
from a technology perspective but also
from a professional services perspective
we introduced a third party called blue
bond and in fact that was Google
suggestion we already had an existing
relationship with glib on so we were
very happy to work with them and you can
imagine what the next eight weeks was
like with a team of people working
around the clock to take this legacy
application to move it into Google cloud
to protect it in this case we used
technologies from both octo and Akamai
to protect access to that application
and we were able to get it up and
running in time for the storyteller
summit now that's not something that we
would necessarily want to do again I
would not encourage anyone in the room
here's a technologist to sign up for an
eight-week mission-critical deployment
to the cloud but we did it and I would
say that it was incredibly rewarding to
work with both Google cloud and glib on
to get that done you can't have a CT on
the stage without an architectural
diagram of course I don't have time to
go into this but what I would say is
that one of the beauties for us in
working with Google cloud was the
flexibility that they brought I think
when tarik made his opening comments he
really brought that home with this focus
on solving business problems the fact
that we had other systems that were
connected to spy and other systems that
were dependent on it wasn't an inhibitor
to working with Google cloud to get this
application up and running so what about
the future we've obviously been able to
take this application and get it into
Google cloud make it available to our
photographers and our internal
stakeholders again and that's been
wonderful in fact I received hugs and
kisses from our photographers as a
result of us having done that but there
is an interesting future one of the
reasons that we chose to work with
Google cloud was our excitement about
tools such as Auto ml and the cloud
vision API that will allow us to do
things such as enriching the metadata
that goes with these wonderful images
that we have in our image collection and
we believe that we can utilize the power
of GCP and some of the native
capabilities in Google cloud to build
even more compelling stories and even
more compelling experiences in the
future but the most important thing is
that the legacy of our photographers is
now safe and these are not just the
legacies of these individual
photographers in some respects they are
part of the legacy of humanity these are
stories that need to be told that people
need to understand and I'm delighted to
say they're working with Google cloud we
were able to secure the image collection
not just for ourselves but for many many
generations to come
[Music]